heures avec roger gicquel le
détournement du boeing de la lufthansa
est liée à la sphère choix hier
aéronautique française
nos exportations doubler en un an grâce
à airbus et aux avions marcel dassault
commerce extérieur pour la première fois
depuis deux ans notre balance
commerciale est excédentaire en
septembre une nouvelle source de
carburant
la paille bonsoir depuis plus d'un mois
monsieur hans flyers le président du
patronat allemand est détenu par un
groupe d'ultras révolutionnaire allemand
depuis plus d'un mois le gouvernement
allemand tente de résoudre cette affaire
par la négociation et on a fini par
oublier monsieur flyers qui dans la
stratégie du commando qui s'intitule
armée rouge et d'autres noms aussi et se
recommandent de la bande à baader en
tout cas devaient servir de monnaie
d'échangé pour la libération de bader et
de ses amis hier entre palma de majorque
et francfort un avion allemand de la
lufthansa était détournée au début on
pense à c'est un détournement de plus on
n'établit pas immédiatement le rapport
entre ce détournement d'avion et la
sphère schleyer pourtant c'était bien le
cas
le gouvernement ouest allemand est
maintenant acculé à une décision rapide
les ultimatums diffusé pratiquement dans
de nombreuses rédactions d'allemagne de
france et d'autres pays d'une manière
qui montre une organisation très
précises de la part des terroristes ils
nous sont parvenues ces messages comme
ils sont parvenus à france-soir ya
d'autres journaux indiquent que si on ne
libère pas les trois chefs survivants de
la fraction armée rouge
andreas baader ainsi que huit autres
extrémistes emprisonné en allemagne +2
palestiniens incarcérés en turquie si on
ajoute pas à ces libérations de
prisonniers
une somme équivalente à 75 millions de
francs
les 91 passagers et membres d'équipage
du boeing actuellement sur l'aéroport de
dubaï dans le golfe persique seront
exécutés à partir de dimanche matin ou
de dimanche midi et on exécutera aussi
en chf meyer c'est la menace qui pèse
dans ses communiqués situation donc
extrêmement difficile pour le
gouvernement allemand nous allons voir
les différents aspects de cette affaire
avec jean paul fleury pour les
différents épisodes de ce détournement
d'avion alain rodier pour son lien avec
l'affairé hier et bernard veulent
r notre correspondant permanent en
allemagne fédérale jeudi 13h30
le boeing 737 palma francfort de la
lufthansa avec à bord 86 passagers cinq
hommes d'équipage et détourner de sa
route au dessus de la côte d'azur en
début d'après-midi l'appareil se pose à
rome pour faire le plein un pirate
disant s'appeler capitaine valter
mohamed demande la libération d'un
groupe de prisonniers politiques détenus
en rfa le plein fait l'appareil
décollent vers chypre vers 20 heures il
se pose à larnaca le chef du commando
qui prétend être un rescapé du camp
palestinien de tal el attar refuse
d'entamer des négociations
même avec l'ol paie il réclame la
libération des membres de la bande à
baader détenus en rfa et de deux
palestiniens emprisonnés à istanbul puis
l'appareil redécollé après une escale à
bahreïn se pose sur l'aéroport de dubaï
vers 5h ce matin là le commando deux
hommes et deux femmes réaffirme les
exigences formulées à chypre délai
accordé jusqu'à dimanche 8h le même
délai que les ravisseurs de hans martin
schleyer c'est le 5 septembre que hans
martin flyer est enlevée au cours d'une
opération de commando d'une rare
violence puisqu'elle provoque la mort de
quatre personnes dont les gardes du
corps du président du patronat allemand
très vite les exigences sont connus la
libération de bader et de ses amis entre
cd est refusée l'opinion est très
partagé seule information sûre l'otage
des photos et des communiqués adressés à
divers journaux
mais depuis le début un avocat genevois
m paillot et l'homme de contact 24
heures sur 24 en accord avec le
gouvernement ouest allemand et la nuit
dernière des nouveaux messages lui sont
parvenues 16 courra à 8h gmt
il apparaît d'autre part d'après mais
que ses communications que le
détournement de l'avion boeing de la
lufthansa intervenu le 13 octobre 1977
est en lien direct avec l'enlèvement de
monsieur hans martin schleier il est à
peu près certain que le gouvernement de
bonn finira par libérer les membres de
la bande à baader qui se trouve en ce
moment en prison
le gouvernement fédéral va décider
peut-être
soir de céder aux exigences et héroïne
pour ne pas mettre en danger la vie des
92 otages retenus à dubaï dans l'avion
de la lufthansa
on attend le détournement d'avion à
soulager le sont ses limites qui pourra
faire libérer la bande à baader et
sauver la vie de monsieur flyers le
patron des patrons qui étaient détenus
depuis plusieurs mois tout cela sans se
mettre l'opinion publique adou autant
l'homme de la rue n'aurait pas accepté
hier de libérer pas d'air et ses amis
pour sauver monsieur flyers autant
aujourd'hui l'opinion publique estime
que la ville de 92 tours y est plus
importante que de maintenir à tout prix
des extrémistes derrière les barreaux
aussi dangereux soit-il nouvelle réunion
tourne mal mans ce soir 23 heures jeudi
matin expirant à vous paraît une bonne
nouvelle que raymond barre aurait bien
aimé annoncé en présentant le budget
pour la première fois depuis deux ans
notre balance commerciale a été
excédentaire en septembre
en chiffres corrigés des variations
saisonnières références habituelles
cela veut dire que nous avons exporté
plus que nous n'avons achetés à
l'extérieur et qu'au lieu d'un déficit
nous avons gagné un surplus de devises
de 420 millions alors qu en août
notamment à cause des vacances nous
avions un trou de près de 2 milliards de
francs
les résultats confirme un rétablissement
progressif donc de notre balance
commerciale que monsieur rossi ministre
du commerce extérieur à tribut à
l'effort à l'exportation des petites et
moyennes entreprises notamment
attention cette bonne nouvelle ne
signifie pas que nous sommes sortis
définitivement de la zone rouge
nous aurons suivant toutes les
prévisions encore des mois déficitaire à
venir et il faut signaler que nous
entrons aussi dans une nouvelle période
de tempête sur le dollar qui baisse
partout dans le monde ce qui pour le
moment ne fait pas le franc mais montre
toutes les difficultés qui règne sur ce
que raymond barre appelle le front
extérieur
emmanuel de la taille même si notre lent
rééquilibrage est loin d'être terminée
cette performance est un indéniable
succès le redressement a toujours donné
la priorité aux établissements
extérieurs et a déjà obtenu la
résistance du franc sur le marché des
changes ce que personne ne nie plus
la glissade du dollar exploité par
l'amérique pour exporter à tout prix
nous aident momentanément à payer le
pétrole moins cher mais à terme et
l'handicapera nos ventes et poussera à
de nouvelles hausses sur le brut
cela suffit à rappeler le caractère
vital de notre commerce extérieur qui
est à la fois une nécessité pour obtenir
notre énergie et nous moderniser et une
terrible contrainte dès que nous
importons plus que nous n'exportons
parce que nous produisons trop cher le
déficit extérieur nous embarque dans les
dettes et la chute du franc et il nous
fait perdre des débouchés ce qui mène
aux industries en péril et créent du
chômage la crise a déchaîné une
formidable guerre mondiale pour arracher
des marchés comme on se battait
autrefois pour conquérir des territoires
et quel que soit le régime politique en
france cela ne changera malheureusement
rien à cette redoutable bataille
extérieur or si nous commencions par
vendre des avions et bien tandis que
l'airbus continue sur sa lancée c'est un
avion qui va vers son attitude qui va
vers son altitude commercial de
croisière concorde lui reste entre
parenthèses pour ces atterrissages aux
états unis de quatre grandes villes
l'ont déjà refusé et pour new york
vous savez qu'on attend toujours la
décision de la cour suprême dans les
heures qui viennent mais en fait pas
beaucoup probablement pas avant lundi
mais de toute façon l'avenir de cet
avion est bouché on le sait maintenant
pourtant le fuselage si élégant du
concorde ne doit pas masquer
l'escadrille des avions français qui
sont à la conquête des marchés ainsi le
président du groupement des industries
aéronautiques et spatiales est optimiste
sur les ventes de l'industrie
aéronautique française et pour cela il
s'appuie sur des chiffres les commandes
à l'exportation à l'heure actuelle
semble montrer qu'elle doubleront en 77
par rapport à l'année dernière avec un
montant escompté de 20 milliards de
francs
c'est ce qu'il a révélé devant les
députés de la commission de la défense
autre jour
pourtant cette bonne situation à
l'exportation ne retentira pas vraiment
sur l'emploi la même les personnalités
de l'aéronautique a laissé entendre que
la réduction des effectifs devra
continuer cette année et l'année
prochaine
le point jean pire kita
avec 18 et peut-être 20 milliards de
francs à l'exportation l'industrie
aéronautique française aura donc doubler
ses ventes à l'étranger qu'il s'agisse
des avions des hélicoptères des
équipements ou des missiles l'avion de
l'année c'est incontestablement l'airbus
ses ventes ont quadruplé en un an
cinq appareils vendus en 76 19 cette
année et ce n'est pas fini puisque sur
un total commandes et options compris de
75 appareils airbus industrie à des
promesses de vente pour une quarantaine
d'avions d'ici à la fin de l'année et
cela sans compter le marché américain
qui pourrait offrir 50 avions en plus
bref si tout va bien plus de 150 airbus
devraient être commandés d'ici un an
satisfaction également chez dassault
briguait où les mirage se vendent comme
des petits pains depuis le 1er janvier
plus de 200 mirage ont été vendus aux
quatre coins du monde
une bonne centaine de mirage iii admire
h5 et autant de f1 le dernier né de chez
nations unies résultats les plus
exceptionnelles concernent les avions
d'affaires de la famille mystère mystère
10 mystères 20 et mystères cinq ans les
ventes ont quadruplé par rapport à 76 34
avions vendus l'année dernière
134 commandé cette année et nous ne
sommes qu'en octobre
dans le même temps les hélicoptères
progresse de 20% et les missiles
représenteront en valeur le tiers des
exportations d'armement soit 6 à 7
milliards de francs
bref qu'à trois mois après le salon du
bourget salon de la morosité
tout va bien seule ombre au tableau et
elle est de taille
conques or même si la chine et l'iran
maintiennent leur option pour l'achat de
six appareils concorde n'a pas et n'a
plus d'avenir vendre des avions c'est
donc une bataille de tous les jours
c'est aussi une leçon permanent de
patience et de ténacité
valéry giscard d'estaing à l'issue des
entretiens officiels de ce matin a rendu
hommage à la figure historique que
représente le maréchal tito et c'est
bien sûr cette impression sur ce fond
d'histoire que s'est déroulée cette
visite à paris en effet le président
titou le président tito est le dernier
de ce que l'on a classé parmi les géants
d'après guerre les parisiens qu'ils ont
assez peu vu quand il est entouré
protégé par une suite très attentive
ont ils ressenti la même impression
c'est en tout cas un tito très présent
et à 85 en participant activement aux
entretiens quatre heures au total que le
président giscard d'estaing à écouter
parler de l'avenir de la détente et
aussi de l'avenir de son propre pays la
yougoslavie que les blocs les grandes
puissances guette du coin de l'oeil
serait un enjeu de taille si elle venait
à se déstabiliser
quito le sait et sa visite en france
s'inscrit aussi dans ce souci de
rechercher le soutien de l'europe au
moment du départ le bilan de cette
visite
gérard saint paul ainsi se termine donc
à orly la partie officielle de ce séjour
du président tito qui va se reposer
quelques temps dans le sud-ouest de la
france avant de se rendre à lisbonne le
président giscard d'estaing aura eu face
à lui pendant trois jours de visite
officielle à la fois à témoin de
l'histoire un leader originale de son
pays entre les deux blocs celui de l'est
et de l'ouest et ossi à 85 ans un
voyageur infatigable indirectement cet
aspect expérience historique voyage
infatigable du président tito fait
partie du bilan
pourquoi parce que il y a peu de temps
le président tito est rentré de chine et
du rss et il a fait sa propre analyse
que constate t-il que même s'il existe
quelques signes furtif d'apaisement
entre moscou et pékin
la réconciliation entre les deux
capitales n'est pas pour demain que
choisit de faire alors dans ces
conditions le président tito et bien il
lance une sorte d'appel à l'europe
c'était ce matin lors de la conférence
de presse commune
nous sommes un pays européen intéressant
dit il en substance
mais nous avons le sentiment d'être
négligés par la communauté européenne
en somme tito se place en position de
demandeur un peu frustré sur le plan
économique par rapport à l'europe même
si depuis la visite de valéry giscard
d'estaing à belgrade en décembre dernier
les échanges ont fait entre la france et
la yougoslavie un véritable bond de 40%
ce désir de rapprochement avec l'europe
bien dans le style original de tito pas
dans le sens souhaité par valéry giscard
d'estaing pour la yougoslavie une
yougoslavie qui doit rester dit il
puissante indépendante et maîtresses des
choix qui détermineront son avenir
les compagnies pétrolières sont les
profiteurs de la guerre de l'énergie et
veulent se livrer au plus grand pillage
de l'histoire si vous croyez que c'est
georges marchais qui vient de dire cela
vous avez perdu
c'est jimmy carter en effet le président
des états unis s'est livré au cours
d'une conférence de presse hier à une
très violente attaque contre les
compagnies pétrolières
il les accuse de faire pression sur le
sénat américain pour que celui ci
repousse les mesures proposées par la
maison blanche dans le cadre de la
nouvelle politique carter de l'énergie
bref c'est la guerre entre le président
et les grands du pétrole qui se disent
attaqués de front
et puis d'une façon générale quand jimmy
carter dit que la bataille de l'énergie
c'est l'équivalent moral de la guerre ça
concerne le monde entier
françois de closets
cette histoire nous concerne tous parce
que nous avons un intérêt vital à ce que
l'amérique des mini ses importations de
pétrole
c'est également d'ailleurs l'avis du
président carter et il a donc prévu
d'augmenter le prix du pétrole aux états
unis en faire baisser la consommation
seulement qui va bénéficier de cette
hausse elle doit servir à augmenter la
production disent les compagnies
pétrolières or la production c'est nous
cet argent doit nous revenir
pas du tout dit le président vous ne
feriez qu'accumuler les profits il faut
redistribuer cet argent aux citoyens
sous forme de diminution d'impôts et en
fait c'est tout le système capitaliste
qui est remise en cause parce que dans
ce système les prix devraient être
libres et les producteurs les
augmenterai pour faire face à leurs
investissements nous faut mais cela ne
peut marcher que si l'on fait confiance
à ses producteurs
or l'opinion américaine ne fait pas
confiance aux compagnies pétrolières et
ça ne date pas d'hier cela a commencé
avec rockefeller seulement la méfiance a
encore augmenté lorsque les américains
au constat
dès que ce qu'un triplement du prix du
pétrole qui leur coûtaient si cher
n'avait fait qu'augmenter le chiffre
d'affaires et les bénéfices tu sais ce
qui était alors celle ci sont
ouvertement accusé d'accroître le risque
de pénurie pour augmenter leurs profits
seulement d'un autre côté l'amérique
n'envisage pas de sortir du système
capitaliste et de confier à la puissance
publique la recherche et la production
du pétrole
quant aux sociétés pétrolières elles
n'entendent pas être contrôlée par
l'état pour l'utilisation qu'elles font
de leur argent alors entre les deux la
production américaines diminuent les
importations de pétrole augmente et pour
que le système marche il faudra bien se
décider
ou bien à jouer le jeu capitaliste ou
bien à jouer le jeu dirigiste en france
l'essence sera plus chère de 21 centimes
au mois de juin prochain et leur a déjà
augmenté de 5 centimes en février les
députés viennent d'approuver cet article
du budget cette augmentation du prix de
l'essence ne sera donc que le fait de
l'impôt mais on ne sait pas ce que nous
réservent les pays producteurs de
pétrole l'algérie était demandeur ces
jours ci d'une forte hausse du prix du
brut
économiser l'énergie où en trouver de
nouvelles sources va donc rester un mot
d'ordre pour longtemps économie énergie
écologie sont d'ailleurs des mots qui ne
font pas que rim et ensemble ils
deviennent inséparables
tout le monde a bien conscience et on ne
compte plus les inventeurs qui travaille
dans cette direction
on a vu on en a vu beaucoup d'ailleurs
de ses inventeurs travailler sur des
économiseurs qui n'ont pu être
exploitées pour la plupart on en a vu
d'autres découvrir de nouveaux
carburants qui faisait long feu or avec
notre confrère l'auto journal
nous avons suivi de très près une
expérience qui est sans doute plus
intéressante que les autres un inventeur
henry repli ce berger déjà détenteur de
quarante trois brevets sur les moteurs
c'est pas n'importe qui travaille depuis
quelques années sur un procédé qui fait
rêver tout le monde
le carburant sans pétrole le carburant
fabriqué à partir d'une botte de paille
de foin ou n'importe quel réseau du
végétal
au début on a pris ça pour un canular et
aujourd'hui les laboratoires d'une
grande compagnie pétrolière s'intéresse
à cette découverte
une table ronde a été organisée avec un
représentant de l' agence pour les
économies d'énergie
mélanger avec de l'essence ce liquide
tiré d'une botte de paille fait rouler
normalement une voiture
évidemment ça pose beaucoup de questions
beaucoup de vérifications
michel chevalet s'est rendu dans le
laboratoire de monsieur rôtissent b
g ou plutôt autour de son alambic de
campagne voici pour l'instant les
conclusions de michel chevalet une villa
à beaulieu sur mer à flanc de colline
sur la terrasse une étrange
installations que ne renierait pas du
bout un autoclave et un alambic mais on
fait avec un vieux fûts du vil et
pourtant cela marche au fond l'inventeur
monsieur refuse berger devant nos
caméras avec deux kilos de failles il va
nous fabriquer en quatre heures de temps
un quart de litre de sang carburant qui
est en fait un alcool l'iso propanolol
première opération met dans l'autoclave
cilic d'eau additionnée de 150 g de
bicarbonate de soude et ont fait mijoter
le tout 45 minutes à 120 degrés ceux des
plus de la cuisine mais ce n'est pas
encore de la chine après avoir rincé le
tout on ajoute deux litres d'eau et 100
g d'isopropyle had d'aluminé en chauffe
45 minutes entre 160 et 170 degrés reste
enfin la troisième opération qui n'est
rien d'autre qu'une fermentation qu'est
ce que c'est comme purement c'est le
secret est alors j'ajoute encore un peu
de cobalt c'est fini votre invention que
vous savez fabriquer facilement cet
alcool à partir de produits végétaux
c'est ça et puis aussi le prix de
revient le carburant
hr revient à moins de 0 50 centimes du
litre toutes taxes comprises
alors que l'essence tel que vous l'avez
à la pompe
elle revient à 0 62 quelle est la
proportion que vous mettez dans les
boîtes urbaine 35% ses bons 46,6 en veut
voilà on en fait
c'est de l'alcool
août est à l'écouté la menace voilà je
sais que michel chevalet la goûter et
puis ensuite et bien ça a marché dans un
moteur une des grandes nouveautés du
premier stade de la réforme haby est la
mise en place dans les écoles primaires
et maternelles d'un comité de parents
d'élèves comité qui dans l'esprit de la
réforme devrait permettre une meilleure
participation des parents à la formation
de leurs enfants pour former un comité
il faut des élections
elles débuteront le 24 octobre jusqu'au
10 novembre tous les parents qui ont des
enfants à l'école primaire ou en
maternelle peuvent voter mais seulement
un par famille pour ceux qui travaillent
le vote par correspondance est permis
quelle est l'importance de ces élections
sont-elles purement pédagogiques
c'est-à-dire dans l'intérêt de l'enfant
ou déborde tel un tant soit peu sur la
politique
un mini dossier de dominique laurie
nous voici donc une fois de plus en
période électorale il ne s'agit pas
encore du grand débat de société prévue
pour mars 78 mais d'une consultation qui
se veut purement pédagogique et qui
intéresse les parents d'élèves des
écoles maternelle et primaire soit trois
millions et demi d'électeurs
l'objectif désigner les représentants
aux comités de parents une des modalités
de la réforme haby ces comités
associé au conseil des maîtres
permettront estime le ministre une
meilleure participation des parents à la
vie scolaire
je crois qu'effectivement cette
participation massive des parents à
réflexion sur l'éducation
c'est un élément important de la
démocratisation qui s'ajoute à ce que
nous avons fait pour le collège unique
est ce que nous avons fait pour
développement l'écho maternelle en
dehors des candidatures personnel quatre
fédérations de parents présentent des
listes la fédération giraudeau la
fédération autonome et les fédérations
lagarde et cornec encore que pour jean
cornec ces nouveaux comités de parents
ne seront guère efficace nous avons
assez dit et vous le savez que ces
comités de parents ne sont qu'une
caricature de ce que devrait être à nos
yeux la participation des parents dans
le domaine scolaire m déjà les deux
grandes fédérations rivales ont
déclenché les hostilités
mais déjà nous sommes loin des problèmes
pédagogue jean cornec accuse le
président lagarde d'être à la solde des
partis politiques de la majorité
antoine lagarde estime que l'alliance de
la fédération cornec et du syndicat des
instituteurs tous deux proches du parti
socialiste
fausse le scrutin s'il s'agit de partie
oui nous avons choisi un parti c'est le
parti de l'enfant de la famille et de
l'éducation
on le voit ces élections qui vont certes
dans le sens de la démocratisation de
l'enseignement avec la participation des
parents à la vie de l'école représente
tout de même un danger si ces élections
ne sont que le prétexte à une bataille
rangée à une bataille politique entre
les deux grandes fédérations de parents
d'élèves et bien il faut avoir le
courage de le dire
le remède serait pire que le mal oui au
lieu de préconiser une journée sans
politiques à la télévision et bien on
demandera une journée sont politiques à
l'école en tout cas le centre
d'information civique organise à partir
d'aujourd'hui un service téléphonique
d'information sur ces élections à
l'école et retenez ce numéro de
téléphone 544 41,66 144 41 66 et là vous
devriez avoir toute la semaine prochaine
les représentants les porte parole des
différentes fédérations de parents
d'élèves avec vous jean claude narcy les
autres nouvelles de ce journal la cote
valéry giscard d'estaing est remonté à
51% c'est le résultat d'un sondage
france-soir ifop
d'autre part un chiffre intéressant
encore 33 % de la clientèle socialistes
se disent satisfaits du chef de l'état
raymond barre lui aussi enregistrent une
remontée de sa popularité avec un
pourcentage égal de satisfaits et de
mécontents le nouvel observateur révèle
une étude chiffrée de la sofres
intitulé la gauche a déjà perdu les
élections sauf si et le nouvel
observateur explique que les conditions
pour la gauche de redressement existe
mais que la volonté est douteuse suis
dans l'article une série d'hypothèses
chiffrait les 96 préfet de métropole ont
participé à l'hôtel matignon une séance
de travail au cours de laquelle raymond
barre a fait le point sur la politique
du gouvernement en matière économique
financière et de l'emploi à l'issue de
l'exposé de raymond barre les ministres
présents ont développé la mise en oeuvre
du crédit du fonds d'actions
conjoncturelle les mesures des dosages
en entreprise en difficultés les
problèmes de la consommation et de
l'artisanat
enfin l'application des mesures
en faveur de l'emploi attentat à
l'explosif contre le ministère de la
justice place vendôme la charge
puissante a détruit toutes les fenêtres
des bâtiments alentour l'attentât a été
revendiqué par le groupe nwa you are
mais pour l'autonomie populaire ce
groupe avait déjà fait exploser un engin
le 7 octobre devant le domicile d'alain
peyrefitte le garde des sceaux concorde
à new york
énième épisode la cour suprême des etats
unis doit dire ce soir si elle est
compétente pour se saisir du dossier
comme le lui demande des responsables de
l'aéroport de new york
les français achètent de plus en plus de
meubles au salon du mobilier qui se
tient jusqu'à dimanche la porte de
versailles en a vendu en une semaine
plus de 500 cuisine et de 2000 tapie
alors qu'amnesty international s'est vu
attribuer le prix nobel de la paix
le responsable de la section soviétique
wallon tato chin a quitté l'union
soviétique avec sa famille sur dix
personnes de cette section
cinq ont été emprisonnés 3 autorisés à
quitter le pays
une autre privés de travail et la 10ème
à démissionner pour avoir vraiment la
paix le congrès espagnol a approuvé le
projet de loi d'amnistié générale
proposée par le gouvernement tous les
auteurs de délits politiques commis
avant le 15 juin dernier seront
amnistiées le professeur barnard a
greffé un coeur de chimpanzés sur un
homme de 60 ans qui n'avait plus que
quelques heures à vivre la suite d'une
grave défaillance cardiaque
son état est jugé au site satisfaisant
que possible
graziella est donc libre depuis la nuit
dernière la famille de patino le roi de
l'état a versé aux ravisseurs la
coquette somme de 1 milliard de centimes
la petite fille âgée de 5 ans a été
retrouvée pleurant à chaudes larmes
devant un bar entre genève et lausanne
le cauchemar est donc terminée pour la
famille et l'enfant nous allons entendre
le témoignage d'une personne qui a
retrouvé l'enfant
moi je suis juste là et j'ai toujours la
petite île à toutes leurs courses à zi
chez maman et moi je la prenne la relève
dans ce jeu la porte de la dalbade enfin
comme un ministre afin de casser la
carnet rose michel sardou épouse et
babeth à ce matin à neuilly sachez-le
peretti qui les a mariés en présence de
tous les amis michel sardou et de
nombreux fans nos meilleurs voeux de
bonheur aux nouveaux époux
pas de nouvelles du voilier français 33
export qui participent à la cour autour
à la course autour du monde
privé de radios le bateau ne peut donc
être situé toutefois il n'y a pas trop
de raisons de s'inquiéter car 33 export
a pris du retard à la suite d'une avarie
quant à neptune est bien son skipper
bernard de guy notre envoyé spécial va
profiter de l'escale du cap pour venir
lundi prochain nous raconter dans ce
journal
la première étape de la course tiercé
dimanche à longchamp 19 chevaux se
disputeront les trois premières places
du prix de satory andré théron vous
proposera son classement demain à 13h
dans le journal de jean claude bourret
enfin à ce soir à 22h30 dans téléfoot
1 pire quand johnny vous fera le résumé
des principales rencontres de la 2e
journée du championnat de france de
première division
le temps est bien le brouillard ne
s'étant pas levé en champagne et dans le
nord-est ce matin les températures sont
restées basses sur ces régions en tout
cas par contre ailleurs il a fait très
beau avec des températures atteignant 23
et 24 degrés dans le sud ouest demain
matin le temps sera frais des
brouillards se formeront dans
l'intérieur mais il ne se dissiperont
que lentement dans les régions du
nord-est
ensuite le ciel sera clair ou peu
nuageux les températures maximales
seront en hausse sauf dans le nord-est
où l'ensoleillement sera plus tardif est
moins important qu'ailleurs
dimanche le même type de temps
persistera on peut déjà donc dire que
nous allons avoir un beau week end
relativement bon
le célèbre piccolo teatro de milan
dirigé par streller et sa non moins
célèbre commedia dell'arte fait
aparis les 30 ans de sa création
actuellement à l'odéon-théâtre de francs
succès fabuleux comme toujours à milan
le piccolo teatro est comme son nom
l'indiqué un tout petit théâtre 600
places mais sa réputation est tellement
grande qu'il a déjà visité 427 ville
donnée près de dix mille représentations
montez 163 spectacle avec 900 comédiens
en tout et il a rendu qui dit mieux
6 millions de spectateurs heureux pour
fêter ses 30 ans d'amour de théâtre
nicole brice est allé à milan passer une
journée avec arlequin pantaléon sonné et
leurs joyeux compères la comédie à
l'heure aussi quel est son secret elles
sont ces crises et je pense l'esprit et
du g des artères c'est angie qui est
toujours nouveau ça vous jouez vous même
fantasio n'y eut plus de mille fois et
je vous ai vu répétition c'est comme si
vous n'aviez pas encore
oui oui vous voyez pas que ces îles sont
des personnages des marques sont des
personnages très confuse où des gens pas
tous les acteurs peut jouer la france
les masques c'est quelque chose qui va
commander sur la terre et on n'arrive
jamais à compléter touchés que les
masques v et il faut annuler
complètement la terre il fait ressortir
seulement les vaincre
elle fait tout pour vous ferai pas car
quand un traditionnel travail gp pas
beaucoup faire des changements de l'est
parce que c'était pour lesquels les
traditions et qui est la sienne
aujourd'hui
au théâtre de l'odéon cette semaine
comme il ya 30 ans à milan
le public qui a été eu c'est un
véritable sentiment de beaune le piccolo
un théâtre d'une perfection jamais
démenti
et rire un peu ça nous manque tellement
bonne soirée à tous au nom de toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité dernier
journal jean pierre pernaut 23h30 merci